greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible q a my name
is Ricky Carter and I will be your host
today so glad that you could join us
today we have another hour packed
program of your Bible questions and we
have the Bible answers
and we have our wonderful panel our
students our Bible students who will be
giving us the answers today from God's
word
well let me introduce you to them here
to my right I have Daniel Perrin welcome
brother Daniel thank you Ricky I'm glad
to be here every time amen good to have
you and next to him we have Shelley
Quinn good to have you sister oh
wonderful to be here and again we thank
you so much for giving us the privilege
to answer questions thank you for
sending them in because we all learn as
we do so amen amen and next to her we
have for the John Dinsey welcome brother
it's a blessing to be here and I agree
we learn as we study in God's word and
the Bible is able to make us wise unto
salvation we should study it amen amen
well before we get into our program
why don't we have a word of Prayer for
the danger could you lead us with prayer
dear father in Heaven
Lord I know that there are people
watching right now who are Desiring
answers not just facts to change the
mind but the Living Word of Christ to
change their heart to change their steps
to give them hope and a future and Lord
as we communicate your words today work
through them to bring people closer to
you closer to the plan that you have for
their life
I pray this now in Jesus name amen amen
amen amen
oh brother before I give you your first
question I want to share with our
viewers at home how they can participate
you can participate one of three ways
you can send your questions in by email
and you can send that to Bible q a at
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3bn.tv or you
can text us your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and then for those of you
who are on Instagram you can send us
your questions in that way as well at
3abn underscore official at 3abn
underscore official all right president
I have your first question you ready by
God's grace amen amen
according to Revelation Chapter 19 Verse
10 what exactly is the spirit of
Prophecy and that was sent to us by
Shelley and it was emailed to us all
right let's go to Revelation 19 10 and
it says and I fell at his feet to
worship Him
but he said to me see that you do not do
that I am your fellow servant and of
your brethren who have the testimony of
Jesus worship God for the testimony of
Jesus is the spirit of Prophecy
so we have here this verse that helps
helps us look at the Spirit of Prophecy
and when we look at First Corinthians
chapter 12 verses 9 through 11 we begin
to see a picture of what the gift of
Prophecy is there we see beginning in
verse 9.
I'm reading to verse 11 to verse 11 to
another Faith by The Same Spirit that's
the Holy Spirit to another Gifts of
healing by The Same Spirit to another
the working of Miracles to another
prophecy to another Discerning of
spirits to another different kinds of
tongues to another the interpretation of
tongues but one and the Same Spirit
works
all these things Distributing to each
one individually as he Wills so you
notice here that in verse 10 of First
Corinthians 12 10 it says to another
prophecy so some are given the gift of
Prophecy and the uh spirit of Prophecy
is the gift of the Holy Spirit it goes
back to the holy spirit so what is the
gift of Prophecy it is really a gift
from the Holy Spirit and so this is uh
something that we need to keep in mind
it is not a person uh it is a gift that
a person receives from the holy spirit
so the gift of Prophecy the Lord has
given us information that we will have
we give the prophecy in the last days
and we have seen it and so I encourage
you to consider this this is also a
verse that when you go to Revelation
chapter 12
in Revelation chapter 12 it says there
in verse 17 and the dragon was enraged
with the woman and he went to make war
with the rest of her Offspring who keep
the Commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus Christ so these
people identify here identified here as
those who keep the Commandments of God
and have the testimony of Jesus Christ
these are God's children in the last
days and they would have the testimony
of Jesus Christ that we read in
Revelation 19 10 the testimony of Jesus
Christ is the spirit of Prophecy so the
spirit of Prophecy will be manifested in
these last days and uh
we again say that is not a person but a
gift of the Holy Spirit it goes back to
the holy spirit amen amen amen thank you
brother
all right sister Shelly I have your
first question
here we go
if I was baptized as a Baptist
do I have to be re-baptized now that I'm
a Seventh-Day Adventist and that's from
Joelle in New York and she texted that
to us
Joelle in my way of looking at this I
see three reasons for re-baptism one is
you didn't understand what you were
doing the first time around and it
really was meaningless because you
didn't understand second Paul there's
one instance of rebaptism in the New
Testament Acts 19 3-5
Paul goes to Ephesus meets some of
Apollo's disciples they'd only been
taught the baptism of repentance that
John preached as he explained the
baptism of Jesus Christ and believing on
him then they were re-baptized because
they learned that information a third
reason would be if a person had
apostasized if they had turned away I'm
not talking about an occasional sin but
if they'd turned their back on Jesus and
been walking in a wicked way living a
life that certainly isn't Christian if
then when the Lord reaches them and they
come to their senses they may want to be
re-baptized again as a public confession
of their faith in Christ
Christ only gave two ordinances to the
church he gave communion which is
acknowledges the death of Christ and the
ordinance of baptism which is his burial
and his resurrection so what is baptism
I've been baptized four times twice when
I was a teenager because I was taught
you got to be baptized to be saved I was
in a New Testament Church and if you
don't get it done just exactly right
you're not going to be saved then once
because I joined a non-denominational
church went down front and I promise you
they dumped me before I knew what was
going on I I mean it was like five
minutes from the time I was down front I
was in the baptismal pool but what
happened is see Joel we're not baptized
into a church we're baptized into Christ
and when we
what baptism actually is the reason that
we are immersed and baptism means
baptism means to immerse we're bearing
an old way of life and coming up to a
resurrection of a new life it's symbolic
of something that God has done here's
what changed my heart Romans 3 6 3-6
therefore we were buried with him
through baptism into death that just as
Christ was raised from the dead by the
glory of the father even so we should
also walk in newness for life for if
we've been United in the likeness of his
death certainly we shall also be in the
likeness of his resurrection knowing
that our old man was crucified with him
that the body of sin might be done away
with that we should no longer be slaves
to sin when I understood the purpose the
meaning of baptism I was baptized again
at the age of 38.
and then when I became a Seventh-Day
Adventist I joined by profession of
Faith this is something to pray about
ask the Lord what you need to do amen
amen thank you sister
all right brother Daniel have your first
question thank you
what is sheol and what is a baton
are these figures of speech from Bible
times
to me it seems that those in the Old
Testament see sheol as a literal place
for example Proverbs 15 verse 24. that's
from Joshua and he sent that to us by
Instagram all right Joshua Hebrew
language time and I'm not a Hebrew
language scholar but I'll tell you what
I have learned sheol is a Hebrew word
found 65 times in the Hebrew text most
often in the books of Genesis job Psalms
Proverbs and Isaiah it's usually
translated as either hell
pit grave and then it's sometimes left
untranslated simply in his Hebrew form
and it simply represents the condition
in death are arresting in the earth in
other words the grave not a specific
single place to which all the dead go
but when we die we rest in the earth in
the grave buried and that is sheol
Genesis 3 19 indicates that it says for
dust you are and to dust you shall
return so when we're laid in the grave
we disintegrate into the Dust so if we
were to look through each of the 65
instances of sheol in the Old Testament
and you can find that word and look it
up and look through one and one at a
time it gives a pretty clear picture uh
of what this word means let me give you
just a few instances Genesis 42 30 38
says if any Calamity should befall him
along the way in which you go then you
would bring down my gray hair with
sorrow to the grave and there's the word
right there to the Grave I would die in
sorrow numbers 1633 says so they and all
those with them went down alive into the
pit the Earth closed over them and they
perished from among the assembly so you
get the picture of this is Cora dathan
in a Byram and their followers and some
of them are then buried in the earth and
they die and that's where they rested
buried in the earth and so you have the
idea of the grave and then job 17 16.
will they go down to the gates of sheol
shall we have rest together in the dust
and we see this parallelism the sheol
resting in the dust and then psalm 16
verse 10 for you will not leave my soul
in sheol that's my life my person nor
will you allow your Holy One to see
corruption and this is quoted by Peter
in Acts 2 31 referring to prophetically
to Jesus who went down into the grave
but did not stay there and so what we
see is that everybody who dies goes down
to the grave sheol but not everybody
stays there abadot abaddin Revelation 9
11 refers to this they had over they had
over them the king of the Angel of the
bottomless pit the abyss whose name in
Hebrew is a badon all right and so a
baton represents destruction everybody
goes down to the Grave who dies but not
everybody is destroyed only the Wicked
the righteous are raised to everlasting
life Proverbs 15 is one of the only two
texts that puts those two words abaddin
and shield in the same verse and it says
hell and destruction are before the Lord
so how much more the hearts of the sons
of men indicating that those two things
are separate
amen thank you sir I appreciate that
blessed with that answer all right
brother Dinsey I have your second
question
second Corinthians chapter 12 mentions
that Paul was caught up to the third
heaven
where is that and what does it mean
that's from Shireen in England who sent
that in Via Instagram
thank you very much
interesting way of reading it
second Corinthians chapter 12 beginning
in verse 1 is the place to start it is
of doubtless not profitable for me to
boast I will come to visions and
Revelations of the Lord I Know a Man
in Christ who 14 years ago whether in
the body I do not know or whether out of
the body I do not know God knows such as
such a one was caught up to the third
heaven this is where your question comes
from
and I know such a man whether in the
body or out of the body I do not know
God knows now it says in verse 4 how he
was caught up into paradise and heard
inexpressible Words which it is not
lawful for a man to utter
so Paul here is talking about that he
was caught up to the third heaven well
where is this third heaven and you
notice that it calls this place the
paradise
and really when you look at the idea of
the third heaven the Jews even had the
idea of seven Heavens but we're going to
stick with what the Bible says yeah and
and the third heaven uh the first one uh
is really considered the atmosphere the
second is that of the Stars
and then of course the third would be
the dwelling place of God
where he is that would be the third
heaven so Paul was blessed with a vision
to go to the very place where God dwells
and he heard things that he as he says
it is not uh what was the one he used is
not um he heard inexpressible Words
which is not lawful for a man to utter
so he was blessed with that let's go to
Revelation 2 7 quickly to get more
information on this place he who has an
ear let him hear what the spirit says to
the church is to him who overcomes I
will give to eat from the Tree of Life
where is this tree
in the midst of the paradise of God so
we have Paul being caught up to the
third heaven the paradise and now we
hear that this there's a tree of life in
the midst of the paradise of God moving
to revelation 22 beginning in verse 1.
and he showed me a pure River of Water
of Life clear as Crystal proceeding from
the Throne of God and of the lamb in the
middle of its Street on either side of
the river was the Tree of Life
which bore 12 fruits each tree yielding
its fruit every month the leaves of the
tree were for the healing of the Nations
and there shall be no more curse but the
Throne of God and other lamb shall be in
it and his servants Shall Serve him so
the Tree of Life Is by The Throne of God
and this will eventually be
moved to the new Earth created by God so
where is it right now it's in the third
heaven and the third heaven is where God
dwells and eventually God's Throne will
be here on Earth amen amen looking
forward to going to Paradise
amen amen all right sister Shelly I have
your second question and this is your
opportunity to give us a four-minute
answer
we hope
all right here's your question Moses
fasted for 40 days the first time God
gave him the Ten Commandments after he
broke the first set did Moses go back up
immediately to the mountain to receive
the second set
did he fast again that's from Bonnie in
Iowa Bonnie I'm looking at my notes and
thinking how am I going to present this
let me just give you the events of what
happened at Mount Sinai in a
chronological order Exodus 20 verses 1
through 17. God speaks the Ten
Commandments in the hearing of all the
people Exodus 20 verses 22 through
chapter 23 33 Moses has gone up into the
mountain God speaks the Civil social and
ceremonial laws to Moses that he wants
to be their constitution Moses comes
down the mountain he speaks to the
people then he writes them in a book of
the Covenant and then he ratifies the
Covenant Exodus 24 of uh verses 7 and 8
he actually built the altar's sacrifice
ratifies the Covenant people are now in
Covenant they've got a constitution that
God is going to be their King Exodus 24
18. now this is after the Covenant was
signed sealed and delivered Moses goes
up in the midst of the cloud for 40 days
and 40 nights and you know what Exodus
doesn't tell us that he fasted but we
know he did those 40 days and 40 nights
because in Deuteronomy 9 9-14 Moses is
talking about this first 40-day period
and he said I fasted 40 days and 40
nights neither eating bread or water and
Wiley was up there we see that God gives
him and I've lost oh in Exodus 25
chapters 25-27 and then 30. God gives
them the instructions to build the
sanctuary and then Exodus 31 18 God
finally gives him the Ten Commandments
written by God's own finger on Star on
Moses comes down the mountain what
happens he finds the people have already
broken the Covenant God knew this God
sent him down the Covenant I mean down
there and he said those stiffness people
let me start all over with you so Moses
goes down he gets so upset he throws
down the tablets breaks them then does
he return up the mountain right away yes
he does but not for 40 days and 40
nights he goes up Exodus 32 32. he's
pleading with the God he wants to he
says oh Lord if you can't forgive their
sin block me out of your book and then
God says no the one who sins I will plot
out of my Book of Life Now understand
the Covenant has been broken
God Moses is up there pleading and God
says hey I'm not going to go with you
nope I I can't because my presence I
might actually consume these people
there are stiff-neck people Moses comes
down to the camp he tells the people
you know you've broken Covenant with God
he didn't want anything to do with you
he's not even going to go with us into
the promised land so then Moses pitches
his tent outside of the camp and he
calls it the tent of uh
the meeting yes thank you I'm trying to
look for the scripture references this
is Exodus 33 and verse 7 and the people
who want to seek the Lord come out there
well what does Moses do he's out there
pleading with the Lord day and night the
people are watching they are beginning
to actually repent and suddenly the
pillar of fire shows up and God starts
speaking to Moses and Moses is pleading
with him and in Exodus 33 12-14 he says
Hey God you said I know you by your name
you found Grace in my sight and he said
if so go with us go with us so God
finally says in Exodus 33 14 my presence
will go with you and I will give you
rest and then he tells Moses cut out two
tablets of stone this is Exodus 34 1 and
he has Moses go back up Moses then is
with the Lord another 40 days and 40
nights which is found in Exodus 34 28
and God renews the Covenant he did
definitely both times he fasted 40 days
and 40 nights but there was an extended
period in between those two trips up the
mountain
thank you sister
all right brother Daniel I've got your
second question and here's your
opportunity to give us our four-minute
answer as well
I've grown up in The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church and believed that we
follow Sola scriptura
however since we quote sister white as
authoritative but not above the Bible
shouldn't our position be Prima
scriptura with the Bible being our
primary source of authority on all
spiritual and moral matters and that
question was emailed to us okay and this
is a special question to me because I
too want to know how is it that God
communicates to me and how I understand
those words amen so first we need to
understand how God's Messengers relate
to what was already written and the
point here is that prophets of the Bible
never changed or replaced God's word
they simply illuminated what had already
been written and revealed by God but
because selfish and weakened Minds
couldn't or wouldn't see how it applied
to them
prophets were sent so imagine walking
into a room wearing a dark room wearing
dark sunglasses and everything in before
you is hazy and dim and then all of
sudden somebody turns on a bright
Spotlight and you say I didn't know that
was there
that's what the prophets did that's what
Isaiah did that's what Ezekiel did
revealed to people from God's word who
was already there that they didn't want
to accept the five books of Moses were
already accepted by all but they didn't
listen to Moses and Jesus said so in
Luke 16 31 and so the prophets were sent
but they didn't want to listen to the
prophets and so in Luke 13 34 Jesus
calls Jerusalem the one who killed the
prophets kills the prophets for example
was Jeremiah was the Prophet Jeremiah
really speaking for god well he was
pointing people back to the principles
and truths and teachings from God's word
but they didn't want to listen to them
they didn't want to hear it until God's
words were fully confirmed and fulfilled
the people had the scriptures but they
did not want to follow them or they did
not understand them this is why Jesus
says in Matthew 22 29 he says you are
mistaken not knowing the scriptures
so Ellen White's role is what the Bible
prophets did since the question asks
about her we don't usually bring out
quotes from Ellen White here but the
question asks and so I want to share one
statement from what she wrote in the
fifth volume of the testimonies for the
church page 665 and listen to this
you are not familiar with the scriptures
if you had made God's word your study
with a desire to reach the Bible
standard and attain to Christian
Perfection you would not have needed the
testimonies the written testimonies are
not to give new light but to impressed
vividly upon the heart of Truth the
truths of inspiration already revealed
man's duty to God and to his fellow man
has been distinctly specified in God's
word yet but few of you are obedient to
the light given additional truth is not
brought out but God has through the
testimony simplified the great truths
already given in his own chosen way
brought them before the people to awaken
and impress the mind with them that all
may be left without excuse amen so at a
time in Earth's history before Jesus
comes when God does want us to have the
full light of his word in the scriptures
God uses Ellen White to illuminate
selected her for a needful Ministry
needed to point the way way back to
God's word and see things that sometimes
we rush over quickly and don't apply to
ourselves so when I read her messages or
God's messages that that she wrote with
an honest heart willing to hear the
reproves of scripture applied to me
and uh they illuminate and they bring to
light things that I tend to pass over
and so now to the phrase Sola scriptura
it's not a phrase used in the Bible it
simply comes from the Protestant
Reformation indicating that we don't
base our understanding of Truth on the
traditions of men but on diligently
seeking God's word this phrase comes
from the Lutheran movement as Luther and
the German princes willingly laid down
their lives to step away from what
humans had layered over the truths of
the Bible and return and let God speak
so if that phrase Prima scriptura is
helpful to you and accurately reflects
how God speaks then I would I would say
use it if that's a good thing for you
Sola scriptura does not mean that we
can't use any other sources other than
the Bible but that it's God's word that
establishes the truth and we must
remember that we don't worship the Bible
we go to the Bible to go through the
Bible to Christ Jesus said John 5 39 you
search the scriptures for in them you
think you have eternal life and this
would be the same of Ellen White's
writings but it is they that testify of
me and you wouldn't come to me for
salvation go to Christ amen amen thank
you very much for that answer
or brother John before I give you your
third question I want to let our viewers
know how they can participate with our
program you can participate one of three
ways you can either you can email your
question to Bible QA
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3bn.tv or you
can text us your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 and those of you who are on
Instagram you can send us your questions
at 3abn underscore official at 3bn
underscore official and one other thing
I want to share with you have you heard
about 3abn bibleanswers.com that's a
great site that you can go to get a lot
of your Bible questions answered there's
questions answering on the second coming
on what happens when you die
the biblical Sabbath so check out that
website 3abn bibleanswers.com
all right brother John
ready for your third question yes here
we go
what is the city of David
is it Jerusalem or Bethlehem and that's
from Steve in Missouri and he texted
that question to us
thank you so much Steve some interesting
thing surface as we look at this and I
would like to point to you a second
Samuel chapter five and it says in verse
seven nevertheless David took the
stronghold of Zion that is the city of
David verse 9 says then David dwelt in
the stronghold and called it the city of
David and David built all around from
Milo or Milo and inward so David went
and became great and the Lord God of
hosts was with him so so the city of
Jerusalem since they were founded had
been called the city of David
however when we go to the New Testament
we see something happening and this
let's go to Luke
chapter 2 and verse 4 and it says and
Joseph went up From Galilee out of the
city of Nazareth into Judea unto the
city of David which is called Bethlehem
because he was of the house and lineage
of David so why is this now in Luke
Chapter 2 called the city of David it's
because David was born in Bethlehem
and that's why it is called here the
city of David the city of David's birth
so let's go to verse 10 Luke Chapter 2
10 and the angel said unto them fear not
for behold I bring you good tidings so
great joy which shall be to all people
for unto you is Born This Day in the
city of David a savior which is Christ
the lord when you go to First Samuel
chapter 16 you will see that David was
born in Bethlehem that's where he was
and that's where Samuel came to the
prophet Samuel to anoint him now it's
interesting that David was a king
Jesus a king there are some similarities
this is interesting David was born in
Bethlehem Jesus was born in Bethlehem we
also have uh that David was a shepherd
and Jesus is the Good Shepherd David
said on the throne as king and Jesus
will sit David said as King in Jerusalem
just Jesus will sit in the New Jerusalem
as our King so there are some
similarities and so which one is it
both both
but in the in Luke Chapter 2 Bethlehem
is called the city of David mainly
because that's where David was born and
they're not too far apart from one
another about four to six miles from one
another this is where you have Jerusalem
and about four to six miles away is
Bethlehem amen amen thank you sir thank
you
all right sister Shelley I have your
third question
this is an interesting one
did Satan inherit expansion of lifespan
as a fallen angel when he got cast out
of heaven
how is it that he cannot die until the
appointed time of Christ's return in
comparison to US human beings how is it
that humans die and the enemy remains
until an appointed time and that was
emailed to us okay
first of all we know that first Timothy
6 16 says only God has immortality so
Satan is a mortal the angels all created
beings are mortal beings
in heaven Satan trafficked lies about
God and if God had snuffed him out right
then and there the rest of the onlookers
of the universe all the good angels that
didn't follow Satan would have
questioned if Satan was correct so
Revelation 12 12 says woe to the
inhabitants of the earth and the Sea for
the devil has gone down to you having
great wrath because he knows that he has
a short time he was granted this short
time I'm going to share something with
you that
is an opinion
although God does not need counsel
from anyone about
approval
of his directions and will his decisions
scripture indicates that God graciously
allows some of his beings to come into
His presence and have input
on his the way suggest ways to
accomplish his will Job 1 6 and 7 says
there is a day when the sons of God came
to present themselves before the Lord
Satan also came among them and the Lord
said to Satan where do you come from
Satan said from going to and fro on the
Earth from walking back and forth on it
now listen to this one I'll read it from
the Amplified Daniel 4 17. this sentence
is by the decree of the Heavenly
Watchers and the decision is by the word
of the Holy ones to the intent that the
living may know that the most high God
rules the kingdom of mankind and gives
it to whomever he will and sets over it
the humblest and lowliest of men
so God is not the authoritarian that
some people
set him out to be
he it is quite plausible that these
Heavenly councils had input
on the decision to allow Satan a short
time on Earth so that he could either
prove or disprove his accusations we do
know however the end of Satan is coming
at Revelation 2010 says the devil who
deceived them was cast into the Lake of
Fire in Brimstone where the Beast and
the false prophet are so did the devil
get an extension of time he was not
under the same obligation of Adam and
Eve at the tree of life of Good and Evil
but Genesis 3 15 God
sealed his Senate saying the seed is
coming he will crush your head amen amen
thank you sister
all right brother Daniel here's your
third question
can you please explain Isaiah chapter 65
verse 20. that's from Bill in North
Dakota and he texted that question to us
okay thank you Bill this has been a
puzzling text for me and others so for
those of you who are watching or
listening let me get you up to speed on
why bill is asking this Isaiah 65 verse
17 says for behold I create new heavens
and a new Earth and the former shall not
be remembered or come to mind okay so we
got the new heavens and the new Earth
now skip down a few verses to Isaiah 65
21 they shall build houses and inhabit
them they shall plant Vineyards and eat
their fruit so this seems to be talking
about the new Earth but then right
between those two texts in Isaiah 65 20
we find this
no more shall an infant from there live
but a few days that's good nor an old
man who has not fulfilled his days
for the child shall die 100 years old
and that's what raises the question in
the new Earth will we be dying at a
hundred years old that doesn't seem to
fit
now this must be understood in the
context of Deuteronomy 28 where God
gives the blessings and curses for
obedience and Disobedience for obedience
God says this there will be the blessing
of home on home and blessing on your
family health blessing on food and
safety animals travel weather and
finances and these are the blessings
that Israel would experience if they
were obedient to God's law and they
would experience them even in the
context of a sinful World which does not
include eternal life and this is the key
right here the blessings that God gives
right now can be experienced in the
context of sin but there will be more to
experience later now for it for um
Disobedience the curse would be the same
on home Family Health Foods safety
animals travel weather and finances and
so now let's go to Isaiah 65 and we go
through that chapter and here's the
basic message in those first 16 verses
God extended to Israel the invitation
the opportunity the pleading that they
would accept the blessings that he
offered Israel did not accept the
blessings and so God says that says
there in verse 17. God still desires
here to bless his people as a witness to
All Nations that it would be a new thing
because it had not yet been fully
experienced and the change would involve
a change of society a change of their
relationship with God before you call I
will answer and even a change of nature
that the animals would be tame and could
God do this well he promised in Ezekiel
34 25 I will make a covenant of peace
with them and cause wild beasts to cease
from the land God had made this promise
so under God's blessing Children Here
born in a sinful world would not be born
to trouble because they would be born as
a part of a flam family who served and
honored the Lord God is actively
bringing about that promise of his
Blessing as much as we are willing or
able to receive it Israel chose not to
receive it which is why God says in
Isaiah 48 17 oh that you had heeded my
command then your peace would have been
like a river and so This Promise in
Isaiah 65 20 is given in the context of
sin and they would have long life but
the full revelation of that promise will
be experienced in Revelation 21 making
it clear that the blessings we can
experience here are only partial on the
way to the full blessing that we will
receive in the new Earth where there
will be long life without sin which
means it will never ever End Amen
looking forward to that
all right brother John I have your
fourth question here and this is your
opportunity for a four-minute answer
thank you
during bible study with my family the
statement was made that wickedness came
from the sons of God angels into
marrying with humans
referring to scripture Genesis 6 verse
2. I went to Matthew chapter 22 verse 30
to explain that Angels do not marry are
there other scriptures to answer this
question that's from Pat who emailed
that to us
thank you so much Pat and yes you have
used a wonderful verse that it says that
the Angels neither marry nor are given
in marriage in they are they don't have
the capacity to reproduce and why are
some people thinking that this the sons
of God are angels we need to go to the
Book of Genesis to see some information
that will help us here
and I first like to start with Genesis
chapter 4 because
after sin enters into the world you see
that Adam and Eve sinned
and then you see later that Cain kills
his brother Abel and then the Lord talks
to Cain and there in Genesis chapter 4
after the Lord talks to Cain it says in
verse 16 and Cain went out from the
presence of the Lord and dwelt in the
land of not on the East of Eden and then
it says and Cain knew his wife and she
can see them bear Enoch and he built the
city and called the name of the city
after the name of his son Enoch and so
we have uh the lineage of Davis is
described there in the following verses
and so there was a separation between
the sons of Adam
that eventually Seth took the place of
Cain I mean Abel that was killed
so they chose to remain faithful to God
while Cain and his posterity they went
out from the presence of the Lord these
were then called the Sons of men while
those that chose to be faithful to God
are called the sons of God so notice
here in Genesis chapter 4
uh verse 25 and 26 and Adam knew his
wife and she bear a son and called his
name Seth for God said he hath appointed
me another seat instead of Abel who came
slow
Abel was a faithful person Seth then
becomes a faithful person and in a
sister verse 26 and to set to him also
there was born a son and he called his
name Inus then began men to call upon
the name of the Lord so through Seth
they continued to call upon the name of
the Lord moving to Genesis chapter 6 we
now see that something happens beginning
in verse one now it came to pass when
men begin to multiply in the face of the
Earth and daughters were born to them
that is the the wicked people the
descendants of Cain they began to
multiply and daughters were born to them
that the sons of God those the faithful
children of God on Earth that the sons
of God saw the daughters of men that
they were beautiful and they took wives
for themselves of all whom they chose
and the Lord said my spirit shall not
strive
with man forever for he is indeed flesh
yet his day shall be 120 years he is
talking about
that they are people they are men they
are they are humans now it says there
were giants on the earth in those days
and also afterwards when the sons of God
came into the daughters of men
and they bore children to them that they
were Mighty Men Who were of old men of
renown then the Lord saw that the
wickedness of man was great in the earth
and that every intent of the thoughts of
the heart was only evil continually so
we have continually so we have here that
the mixing of the sons of God the
faithful with the mixing of the sons of
men that were Unfaithful that went out
from the presence of the Lord the mixing
of them uh then we see the corruption of
the human race to the point that uh the
thoughts and uh intents of the heart
will only evil continually
so where do people get the idea
that the sons of God are always Angels
is not the case
you see in for example in Luke chapter 3
I'm going to read two verses really
quick uh talking about the descendants
of Jesus it says which was the son of
Methuselah which was the son of Enoch
which was the son of Jared which was the
son of malalia which was the son of
Canaan which was the son of Venus which
was the son of Seth which was the son of
Adam which was the son of God so you see
Adam was called a Son of God and those
who chose to be faithful are called the
sons of God and so this is this is
really uh the distinction between the
two that's what is being said here in
Genesis chapter six and so my time is
gone so I have to stop right here good
answer amen thank you brother oh it's
sister Shelly I have your fourth and
final question
can you explain Hebrews chapter 10 verse
26 does it mean even if we repent and
are sincere and turn away from that sin
that it will not be forgiven that's from
Tracy in Tennessee and she texted that
to us
Tracy this was this the first time I
read this scripture when I was a
teenager I remember my knees knocking
let's look through this we'll begin with
Hebrews 10 26.
if we sin willfully after we have
received the knowledge of the truth
there is no longer remains a sacrifice
for sins
first of all this is not describing an
isolated Act of sin the form of the
Greek verb willful is a habitual
practice a hostility to Christ
premeditated sin living in a state of
continued sin so it's after we
understood is what the scripture says if
we've received it now after we've
received the knowledge of the truth if
we understand the Everlasting gospel
Revelation 13 8 that Jesus Christ is the
Lamb that was slain from the foundation
of the world that God had a plan to save
us before he even created us if we have
full if we're fully aware of that and
have knowledge of his atoning sacrifice
and the gift of salvation by grace
through him if we turn away there is no
other religion on Earth that can save
you there is no other acceptable
sacrifice for sin than the death of
Jesus on the cross so look at verse 7.
so it's saying there's no longer a
sacrifice for sin
27 Hebrews 10 27 but a certain fearful
expectation of judgment and fiery
indignation which will devour the
adversaries and he says anyone who's
rejected Moses law dies without Mercy on
the testimony of two or three Witnesses
of how much worse punishment do you
suppose will he be thought worthy who
has traveled the Son of God underfoot
counted the blood of the Covenant by
which he was Sanctified a common thing
and insulted the spirit of Grace willful
sin
willful sin
counts
blood of Jesus Christ as an Unholy
common thing if we reject Christ we
won't find another sacrifice
in all the world that will cover our sin
but his sacrifice is only good if our
hearts are repented so let me say this
if you the the problem with willful sin
is it can lead you to the unpardonable
sin will you finally grieve away the
Holy Spirit if your heart
wants to return to the Lord that's the
Holy Spirit working in you you've not
committed the unpardonable sin will God
forgive you if you ask for forgiveness
first John 1 9 says not only will he
forgive you of all sin when you confess
your sin but he will cleanse you of all
unrighteousness he will put you on a
right path and if you have any question
about how God can restore an apostate
look up this King manesses history in
Second Kings 21 and second chronicles 33
Amazing Grace yes amen amen thank you
sister
all right brother Daniel here's your
fourth and final question
can you please explain Leviticus chapter
8 verse 23 and that was texted to us all
right I remember reading this on a read
the Bible in a year program when I was
maybe I don't know 12 or 13 years old
and this refers to the consecration of
Aaron and his sons as priests described
in Exodus 29 and then experienced for
the first time in Leviticus 8. it's what
Moses saw on the mountain and reported
to the people and recorded in those 13
Chapters at the end of Exodus it was an
acted out drama that even the children
could watch and see where there was a a
consecrating sacrifice and some of the
blood was placed upon Aaron and his sons
the lobe of their right ear and the
thumb of their right hand and the
the big toe of their of their right foot
and the Bible here does not give an
appendix that says here's what all this
means and so we rely upon scripture and
the holy spirit to guide us so you have
this Blood of a sacrifice it's called
the realm of consecration Exodus 29 19
Aaron and his sons were to lay their
hands upon the head of this Ram an act
of confession and then the blood of that
sacrifice to forgive sins was then a
physical reminder of physical visible
mark on them of their consecration by
the sacrifice of Jesus and confession of
their sins it was placed on the right
now apart here stands for the whole all
right there's nothing against
left-handedness but the right represents
power and right and the part is the
whole kind of like Peter saying Lord
wash my whole body and Jesus says I just
need to wash your feet and so the
dominant hand was the right hand and
this is the hand of power so it
represents consecrating the whole person
and that blood was placed on their ear
because the Great controversy is one of
words and deception and God's priests
should listen carefully and what should
they hear well the Bible was not written
down in a book that everybody could have
they didn't read the Bible with their
eye God's word was given by the ear they
could hear it there was read to them and
so they were to be attentively listening
to God's instruction let me give you
just a few great texts he who has an ear
let him hear Proverbs 1 20 says wisdom
calls aloud outside John 10 27 Jesus
says my sheep hear my voice Isaiah 55 3
and Cline your ear and come to me first
Samuel 15 22 has the Lord great delight
and burnt offerings and sacrifices as
much as in obeying the voice of the Lord
listen they were to listen and their
thumb this is your action this is your
life work what you do with your hands
and the thumb particularly gives you the
ability to grasp what do we hold on to
what do we hold and how should we hold
we should hold Jesus and hold him
tightly and the big toe this is your
walking to be purposeful when we were
walking to be balanced and unwavering
going in the direction that God directs
you and running hard to run without a
big toe Galatians 5 16 says I say then
walk in the spirit Leviticus 8 34 and 35
then tells us that they did this for
seven days and the people could gather
around and watch it the service was
repeated the priest stayed at the door
of the sanctuary meditating on and
rehearsing the service the whole service
of what Jesus did for them and so all of
this that the kids get to watch taught
them the exalted sacredness of the
office of ministry and the calling to be
a minister for Christ amen amen amen
powerful that's great well I know I've
been blessed we've found all these
answers from the word of God were you
blessed well I want to encourage you to
don't go away we're going to be back
here in just a moment and I want to
remind you you're going to see how you
can participate with Bible q a
if you're enjoying our 3abian Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
thanks for staying with us want to get
some final thoughts from our panel
sister Shelley yes Exodus 34 Verse 1 is
where God tells Moses cut these stones
out and come back up when Moses went up
the second 40 days this is when God
gives him additional he renews the
Covenant gives him additional ceremonial
laws and other things but then at the
end God again writes The Ten
Commandments with his own fingers and
you know what that first 40 days he
comes down the mountain and his brow is
furred and he knows he's going back to
idolatrous people but the second time
that he came down after those 40 days
his face was shining with the glory of
God amen amen
brother John I'd like to read something
about the sons of God here and notice in
John chapter 1 verse 12 but as many as
received him to them gave he power to
become the sons of God even to them that
believe on his name First John 3 1
behold what manner of love the father
hath bestowed upon us that we should be
called the sons of God so the sons of
God are those that choose to be faithful
not necessarily angels amen and brother
yes I just want to say studying the
Bible is exciting and we don't have all
the answers I don't have all the answers
but I love coming back to it and saying
Lord help me to understand so I
encourage you to pull out your Bible
each day pick a book any one of them and
say Lord help me to see Jesus in this
book of the Bible and how much he loves
me how much you love me give me the
promises give me the strength and the
grace and the power I need for today
amen amen well friends Jesus is coming
soon are you ready to meet him I am and
I want to remind you with this little
scripture song set your affections with
things above not on things of the earth
Colossians 3 verse 2 God bless
foreign
[Music]